[Music]
major league baseball season has been
pushed back until at least april 14th
when negotiations stalled over the new
collective bargaining agreement the
baseball commissioner canceled another
93 games yesterday in communities that
rely on spring training tourism a
billion dollar business have empty
stadiums and are getting hit hard chris
vancleave is outside globe life field in
arlington texas
chris um i guess we're not singing take
me out to the ball game anytime soon
no there's no singing at all in fact the
rangers had hoped to start their season
here in less than a month and fans were
really hoping for just a sense of
normalcy a spring training without
capacity restrictions without mask
mandates and local businesses were
hoping for a much needed boost now all
of that is on hold but this time it is
not the pandemic that's threatening to
keep the boys of summer benched
the stands at ed smith field in sarasota
will be empty once again today the
spring training home of the baltimore
orioles should be buzzing with excited
fans soaking up the florida sun and 45
minutes south the world champion braves
are also yet to take the field at their
spring training home in venice florida
we definitely are looking forward to
watching the braves instead we found
these fans outside the locked gates of
cool today park on what should have been
their first time at a spring training
game well it's disappointing because
it's my day off it's my son's day off
and we wanted to come and see a game but
it looks like the politics got the best
of us here spring training is big
business the florida grapefruit league
draws around 1.5 million fans generating
nearly 700 million dollars in arizona
the cactus league rakes in about 644
million from 1.8 million fans more than
half from out of state it's very
frustrating for the business community
heather caston is the president and ceo
of the greater sarasota chamber of
commerce she says spring training is
worth about 63 million dollars to local
businesses and the orioles generate
roughly 500 seasonal jobs the people who
are working at the stadium who maybe
this is their second or third job
those you know the people who support
all of the services that go along with
spring training
they're the folks that are going to be
impacted also impacted mike quillen's
geckos grill and pub restaurants it's
kind of the gravy on top of everything
that we really look forward to
to to it every year it's certainly not
been the best time to be in the
restaurant business a little extra
sounds pretty good right now
a little extra sounds great but uh you
know it's been a challenging a
challenging two years major league
baseball says if there is a season it
wants four weeks of spring training but
that can't happen until there's a deal
with the players putting a nearly 11
billion dollar business at risk
baseball's last labor breakdown led the
cancellation of the 1994 world series
attendance didn't fully recover for more
than a decade is there a risk to
baseball that
the millionaires negotiating with
billionaires
alienates the fans yes of course it does
and especially when you negotiate the
public and you remind each everybody
each day how much money you all make it
alienates the casual
fan and that's that's where the damage
gets done that's why they have to do
this deal now and they know it
chabon who you just heard from there was
the general manager of the cincinnati
reds back in 1994 he says the biggest
difference between now and then casual
fans have a lot of entertainment options
many of them right here on their phone
so baseball could be singing the blues
nate for years to come
see what you did there chris thank you
so much